I think for me uh more recently this
label of being a covered dissident has
come from my U-turn if you like or I
would more likely want to describe it as
evolution in my understanding of the
benefits and harms of the covid-19
vaccine specifically the MRNA vaccine to
the Pfizer moderna vaccines
um and I was actually one of the public
advocates
very early on in the pandemic
um when the vaccine rollout started in
in December of 2020 January 2021
I was one of the first to take two doses
of the fisa vaccine
and a month later I was actually on Good
Morning Britain
trying to help tackle uh in a
compassionate way vaccine hesitancy
which was particularly prevalent amongst
the ethnic minority communities in the
UK and I know that's similar in the US
because I convinced a friend of mine
who's a well-known film director called
garinda cheddar well known for movies
like Bend It Like Beckham Blinded By the
Light which is on Bruce Springsteen
um she was receiving a lot of what at
the time I felt was in quotes
um anti-vax misinformation through blogs
and asked me around
um whether or not she should take the
vaccine and I I said to her listen
vaccines and I still believe this to be
the case in traditional vaccines
certainly uh one of the most safest
pharmacological interventions in the
history of medicine so I didn't in any
way shape or form even conceive of the
possibility
of any vaccine causing significant harm
let alone the covered vaccines
but over a period of around a year Brett
um
my
um opinion changed quite significantly
because of a number of different events
um probably the first that made me think
about it was my father who was a retired
doctor
um the honorary vice president of the
British Medical Association very
well-known doctor he suffered
um a unexplained and unexpected sudden
cardiac death in July of 2021.
um I was actually involved in the whole
uh in the events leading up to his death
because he'd called me
um he was suffering from chest pain
which sounded cardiac I was in London he
was in Manchester so a couple hundred
miles away
and we were on the phone and in between
our phone calls he suffered a cardiac
arrest which was witnessed by
two of his neighbors were doctors and
despite the fact that they uh carried
out CPR immediately and ambulance was
called there was a delay in the
ambulance Etc and I was down the line so
it was quite a harrowing experience for
me but
um and of course he was also on a
personal level I was very very close to
him he was my best friend I knew his
lifestyle habits inside out he was the
last surviving member of my immediate
family so I had a quite a profound
effect on me but
um because of the fact that he was
otherwise well and I knew his cardiac
history which was non-significant
um I I asked for a post-mortem to be
carried out
and it's post-mortem findings were quite
shocking he had two critical or severe
stenosis or narrowings in three out of
three of the major arteries two of them
were severely narrowed and um that would
suggest certainly compared to scans I'd
organized a few years earlier just
routine stuff they had a rapid
acceleration of of his blockages so you
know my area of interest and research a
lot of my advocacy over the years Brett
has been on changing the understanding
of our heart disease develops but also
what can be done to even potentially
Halt and even reverse heart disease
that's you know I've published on this
stuff extensively you may be aware of
that work so if anybody had has
expertise in understanding this it's me
and it didn't make sense and the only
thing I could attribute it at the time
my only explanation which again didn't
fully fit but I thought well you know
you have to think about all the
possibilities was my father under very
profound severe psychological stress
that caused an acceleration of his
Coronado disease
um and then a few months later
a number of different bits of data
emerged
um which for me started to put a picture
together to suggest that the MRNA
vaccines could be
um that a major cause behind my dad's
death and of course many other uh
unexpected cardiac arrests and heart
attacks and that was first and foremost
there was an abstract published in
circulation by Stephen gundry which
suggested that the MRNA vaccines were
causing huge coronary inflammation
through inflammatory markers that would
increase cardiovascular risk very
rapidly
um at the same time a colleague
from a very prestigious British
institution I won't name name that
institution
um to protect his uh identity but he
basically said that um researchers at
his institution had accidentally found
by use of coronary Imaging that the
vaccinated versus unvaccinated were
having huge
um increases in uh coronary inflammation
as well
having found this they decided they had
a closed meeting that they were not
going to publish these findings because
they were worried about
the fact that they may lose funding from
the pharmaceutical industry and then
only a few weeks earlier I had been
contacted by a journalist for the Times
newspaper and actually given an
interview
where she said that there was reports
from hospitals in Scotland of a uh
unexplained rise in heart attacks about
25 increased risk and heart attacks
which were not associated with covid and
asked me what was the cause of that now
before I'd become familiar with these
potential harms from the vaccine I had
again attributed it to
maybe the knock-on effect of lockdowns
poor diet and stress because actually
the major factors normally in the
development of heart disease 80 of heart
diseases is lifestyle related are issues
such as poor diet sanitary lifestyle
poor sleep and and chronic psychological
stress so I had predicted there probably
would be a signal anyway coming in the
next few years even when the pandemic
started from those factors and I still
think they probably play a role
um but then I decided Brett after all of
this to
um first and foremost as a my duty as a
doctor and because I have a public
profile I went on GB news which is a
news channel over here and I said that
you know I'm concerned there may be a
significant link here between the MRNA
vaccines and heart heart attacks and it
needs investigating
um that video went viral
um I had to put up behind the scenes
many people don't know this but after
that um I had a couple of very uh um
let's put it this way a medical
organizations linked to my medical
license and my affiliation my
postgraduate um credentials essentially
contact me because of complaints that
were made by Anonymous doctors I was
promoting you know anti-vaxx information
Etc so I had to deal with that in the
meantime over a few weeks and that
luckily didn't end in any specific
censorship
um but I then decided what I needed to
do really to open this up is to spend my
time
critically appraising the data
thoroughly and then publishing it in a
medical journal and I did this over a
period of nine months and as you
probably know
um a few weeks ago I published these two
papers in the Journal of incident
resistance where I had concluded
um unequivocally based upon the evidence
that the um the MRNA vaccines need to be
suspended uh pending an inquiry because
the signal of harm is significant and
it's based upon very high quality
evidence now
it is a long answer and there are quite
a number of things I want to return to
in there but I think first and foremost
let me just say
um that's a terrible story about your
father and uh I'm you have my
condolences and I'm sure my audience is
properly shocked by
um what must have been uh
uh at a terrible
realization not only of his passing but
of the possibility that
um your profession had been involved in
some way in advancing a therapy that had
this terrible terrible consequence so
anyway thank you Brad and then on that
note the irony of this is my father
obviously it had two doses of the
vaccine early on he had actually
convinced me because I realized I knew I
was low risk from covert and I'm sure we
can talk about that a bit later but
um he had really convinced me
emotionally because you know he had lost
his wife my mother a few years ago just
to get into the human side of it and I
think that he like many people who are
older had a a very I would say
exaggerated fear of covid
and for him obviously I'm his you know
only surviving son
um and uh he you know he was worried
about me and he said listen please you
know and actually one of the main
reasons I had it was because I didn't I
didn't necessarily need to have it so
quickly I could have waited it's because
of him uh and also as somebody that was
the honorary vice president of BMA and
he also was a prolific writer he did a
lot of media work he was a very strong
Advocate again for the vaccine as well
so that's also you know they're they're
thrown into the picture which
complicates the situation
yeah it sure does I I will say
um I also received pressure from people
who loved me and wanted me to get
vaccinated
um and in in fact at the beginning of
the vaccination campaign I thought I
would I was pretty excited about the
vaccines
[Music]